you really sucked up the gravy with that
entropy people when they respond that
way you got to make them feel good about
their decision yeah they stood up they
said the kids here I said give them a
little thrill yeah yeah you get about
six laps and there's really not much
time left here for a few more laps I'm
sorry you're gonna see right there
first of all let's address coming from
that commercial going into that last
commercial you claim I am NOT a classy
man and I don't oh is just a fun little
dig against an old friend you better
know what the word fun means that was
hurtful
I also by the way I'm gonna quote my
wife I don't know who I think I am
wearing this jacket I don't know what
I'm wearing yeah look at that it is am i
a ringmaster my Siegfried am i Rory what
am I where is that you know it is
there's a weird a little yeah it's this
part right here that I fight Bing that
bothers you no I just I want to look to
you and say can you take me to the
eighth floor please you know oh you
think it's bellhop yeah I think it sort
of bellhop and guy who elevates an opera
you know whatever elevator operator yeah
hitter I know it's also got a little
additional pocket over here mm-hmm that
I keep my hopes and dreams right okay my
hopes and dreams right there very small
pocket yeah I see there's a there's a
hole in it
now listen zing
applaud him I wanna hear every night
upon me I want to thank you you invited
me hit when you touch him he's mine I
say mine
oh I want to thank you you invited me to
your podcasts the podcast athan it's for
a great cause and I had a lovely time
audience was terrific
you're a great host I really had a good
time we know we had a great time we
raised as you mentioned we've raised one
hundred fifty seven thousand dollars on
Saturday there's a great we do the event
for Smile Train explain what that is
Marta happy to it's a great organization
that goes to third world countries
to fix the cleft palates and cleft lips
of children that couldn't otherwise
afford to have that changes their lives
changes their life so for two hundred
fifty dollar donation you're basically
changing a child's life and we've been
doing this now for nine years and I just
got the text as I was coming to the
stage we just crossed we have raised 1
million dollars for you one thing you're
milking it a bit there too it's for the
children is for the children listen you
had an option and I was just curious
because obviously you were you were
auctioning off some pretty cool stuff I
was wondering was there anything that
didn't sell I'm always hot with a
negative thing that really didn't sell
an option well you know we had great
ones where we had like you get a tour of
the Conant studio yeah that went for all
those things go through the roof oh you
get to sit on a podcast taping of my
podcast the award-winning never not
funny okay and everything went for a
great amount of money the only thing to
kind of crap the bed was we had a guy in
our band by the name of Ken Robinson who
is a Broadway performance acts alone on
Broadway yeah he is a known jazz
saxophone player he donated lessons to
learn the saxophone yeah and it got zero
bids what do you think was going on I
think what it is is nobody likes the
saxophone
that has to be the right Gary you don't
what I'm talking about that's what not
get out Sakata nobody cares for the
saxophone what kind of reference was
that John Sakata no was that I mean
unless you're doing the heaters on
nobody cares for the sax Janet that
Donna I don't like to speak ill of the
dead but God flashed it that's a
horrible song now listen you've you came
out here this audience loved you you
told them how much you've raised for
charity yes and then you went after the
saxophone in a way that horrified this
audience and I think American if the
people at home as well I think so too I
think it's a beloved instrument Jerry we
love you I don't know what's wrong with
this monster like this you pitted them
against me thing that you're doing at
all you went after what a guy in my band
and who didn't let me finish know if
they were trombone lessons they should
have gone through the roof
yeah Jim has little trombone swivel hips
okay I don't know what you're talking
about now you there was nothing sexy
about the trombone I'll tell you that I
don't think there's the trombone is this
a I think it's the sexiest of all the
brass what are you talking about it said
look at the way it goes it out comes
back in that's a sexy horn that's a sex
yard what's the second code in sorry
what is a you didn't when I'm said you
didn't have class I was wrong
apologize
you